baffling to me because so again i
covered the ncaas uh last week and there
was pro lgbtq protesters there you know
standing up for leah thomas and i'm
standing there talking to these college
age kids and it's such a surreal moment
when you have someone look at you in
your face and go yes a woman can have a
penis yes men can get pregnant and yes
men can have periods and again you know
this is rhetoric that we've seen time
and time again this is nothing new but
actually hearing somebody say that to
you to your face bold face completely
believing it just shows me how far gone
we've become like as a country to where
there's no basis in reality at all
anymore this is why people talk about
national divorce it's why they talk
about civil war it's not so much about
look i don't care those people can
believe whatever they want they can
watch whatever movies they want to make
and do that and then what do we get we
get the daily wire making their own
razors we get the daily wire making
their own movies we are certainly
interested in moving that direction as
well with our own cultural content we
just need to stop
trying to be a part of their club that's
that's one of the most frustrating
things to me like i don't care if these
people walk around thinking that they're
you know uh clowns juggling bananas like
that's cool dude you do your thing man
i'm gonna be hanging out here with my
friends like having a beer and playing
guitar that's our thing you do your
thing but the problem is conservatives
keep begging to be in their club and
they need to stop doing it republicans
do it all the time they're they freak
out because right now gop racist is
trending on twitter it's like so what do
you think they're so weak and pathetic
there's so many spineless rhinos in our
congress right now in our just political
space as a whole they're so spineless
they're so pathetic and the reason why
conservatism as a whole has completely
deteriorated is because people like matt
schlapp who's supposed to be the creator
of the conservative political action
committee is coming forward and saying
oh leah thomas's journey we really need
to have empathy about it because uh you
know her story is important are you
freaking kidding me right now yeah
conservatism is pathetic in the modern
day well it is i agree with that but i
also agree with what matt was saying if
these women at the ncaa don't care to
speak up if none of the if none of their
family members will speak up then they
deserve they deserve whatever whatever
they're experiencing that's not what
matt was saying matt was saying that he
thinks that we should have empathy
towards leah thomas i completely
disagree again i'm not a female athlete
i'm not the one that should be
protesting you and i are actually
talking about this uh before the start
of the show why did these females even
compete with thomas why didn't because
they liked it
this is one of the most frustrating
things to me because the ncaa women have
publicly come out and agreed with leah
thomas and supported her and the only
person who didn't the only person so far
to come out complaining is the person
who got bumped by one space
16th place but that got deleted what
teammate so that is who i interviewed
last week that's the news we broke
tucker carlson played it on his show her
teammate rose pouch uh she spoke out on
behalf of her said her teammate was
crying all right but she wasn't in the
finals either right uh no she was in the
final she got first place in the 200 uh
yard free she spoke out against the
thomas because she watched her teammate
cry as thomas took that final spot again
uh i can't pronounce her name correctly
rick
yogi yes that's her name uh she was
going to respect someone coming out and
actually speaking so that's that's what
i'm saying tim so it's like it's not
that all of these athletes aren't
speaking out it's that they're being
completely silenced now we made national
news with that it's completely been
deleted off of twitter you can't find it
anywhere all of the national news
articles that were linked to her
interview completely gone right now this
is the point in this that i want to that
i want to bring up is first of all matt
schlapp saying that we need to have
empathy on this person's journey who by
the way has a clear and present bulge
actually bigger than mine so i'm taking
some notes here but i will say you know
that's that's completely crap and
conservatism definitely is in the
position to where people are fighting to
conserve things that do not exist and
have not existed for some time including
this entire country for at least 100
years as they've been divul uh we've
been developing into some crazy
globalist empire but with the specific
thing with with the the
swimmers i don't think it's enough to
just say like it's their fault because
we've gotten in used to everybody in
every
field in every department institution we
already assume they have to be activists
because everybody everybody seems to be
one journalists are activists professors
are activists and now we're saying look
there's people who just want to swim
they do not want to get involved in
political things in fact one of the
greatest things i have found and has
kept me sane has been lifting weights
getting back in shape and i go onto
twitter and i put like one thing up like
yeah hey you know i did my 5x5 at 225 on
chest i'm excited to hit a goal and
there's all these bros that get in there
that are like oh man what's your squat
what's your this what's your that and
i'm like dude you're complicating
something i picked up heavy things
i put them back down i know there's a
science to this i know people get really
involved i'm not doing that where are
these girls
there's a point to be said to this
though good question but there's a point
to be said that's why i don't care no no
because but here's the point what you're
asking for and i'm saying this genuinely
some people i've i know people that are
into swimming for instance and they just
do it to clear their mind they do to get
their mind off the road and focus on the
goals
my point is as i'm saying people always
try to complicate things a lot of these
swimmers are put in a tough position
that they their scholarships might ride
on this they might come from
impoverished families
listen and maybe that just maybe when
you're when you're focused on breaking
generational like wealth gaps and you go
to a nice school and you're trying to
swim and get your family out of that
poverty that idea of getting out of
poverty is more important to you than a
social issue like transgenders and you
don't know what to do so what's
happening in our world is no matter
who's out there we are demanding of them
to be political activists what should be
happening is this discussion should be
happening at a senior level with
administrators and with individuals who
are put in those political positions to
try to debate whether something is
ethical but the swimmers themselves i
don't blame them for not knowing what to
do because like that girl who was scared
these are genuine people who are going
even if i speak out will it change
anything and they don't have they're not
they don't they can't have they can't
afford what you no no no no no no no
we're stopping right there bro i am sick
and tired of hearing about spineless
people who don't stand up for themselves
who think they're entitled to everything
that's one of the big issues i have with
the left they come out and they say we
should get free college we should get
free vet i shouldn't have to do anything
for it these swimmers won't come out
their dads won't come out their moms
won't come out now there was one woman
who spoke anonymously and then you come
here and you say they don't have all of
this bro
not only did i come from the gutter but
i've consistently stood up for my values
i've had people on this show who have
been censored over and over again and i
know there are hard limitations because
there are certain things that makes
that's difficult for either ui to talk
about on our shows but i quit a
corporate gig i tried to break a
contract with millions of dollars
because they wanted me to do woke bs now
for me i'm i'm not saying anybody has to
have my back on that i'm saying i take
care of myself i don't think i'm
entitled to or owed anything so when i'm
at a company and they say you want the
money we're paying you we have you under
contract you're going to do woke stuff i
said no i won't and they said well you
better and i said i guess i'll just sit
here or you can break my contract but
they said political commentary yeah can
i call you i was not a political
commentator when i worked for abc to
some extent though but you're in the
visuals you're into somewhat of
entertainment like a lot of these people
are just athletes and they're like dude
i didn't ask for this like i don't know
what's wrong and they're athletes trying
to figure it out so we gotta give them
some time don't wanna be political
activists they want to be able to just
focus on their sport i completely agree
with what you're saying tim but i also
think that this is your passion this is
your career right swimming is those
girls passion they don't want to be
political activists well the big reason
why their parents don't want to speak
out for them is because the daughters
ask the parents hey you know what just
don't do it i don't want to face the
repercussion i don't want the ncaa
coming after me the ncaa told these
athletes don't mention leah thomas's
name in the locker room do not speak to
any media so the fact that i even got
that interview that's why it went so
viral because the ncaa has been
silencing these women i understand what
you're saying tim because i'm the exact
same way i'm hardline and i say stand up
for your rights stand up for your
country or you will lose everything but
at the same time we do have to remember
we're in this spot because not everybody
is a political activist unfortunately
that i'm not going to uh i'm not going
to stand up for people who haven't asked
for it yeah like it is the most insane
thing to me that you have people being
like we must defend these young women
who are actively publicly supporting
leah thomas i'm like dude have like what
are you talking about what's that i
don't know but i don't know
supporting leah thomas and they're
acting like they're mad when they're not
no no because that's not even the point
i'm saying
we tend to be in politics and i'm not
saying you but just in general is
reactionary where we expect that people
move on our time we consume stories by
the daily there are people that i met i
met an uber driver that didn't even know
there was a war in ukraine okay like he
didn't even know it was happening people
in the world are sometimes so focused on
a goal that they even disconnect that's
even required of them to get off social
media etc and they don't know what's
going on
there is a problem that we see
the problem is is that the swimmers need
to see how big of an issue this is of
letting a man compete against women in a
way that will always beat them will out
qualify them and would fundamentally
change the country i'm saying i don't
believe all of them see that because i
remember being around non-political
people who are like okay this is weird
but i'm being told this is right
especially if they don't have any more
if they don't have any moral absolution
or maybe they're not even that high iq
then i'm saying they might be saying i
don't know what to do so before i'm
judging them for not swimming i'm saying
i think a lot of them are weighing their
they are weighing their options and more
importantly like you said how you would
have turned down a contract i think a
lot of them will lose out on their
opportunities and i think this is where
you start
willing to stand up but you see them
getting birthed somebody is going to get
red
stand up and it might set it up how long
has been this has been going on for 14
years in the public spotlight if we
track the data going into the new york
times 14 years 14 years parents are not
speaking up they're not going to
meetings the fathers and the mothers are
not showing up to meetings and saying we
want rule changes they don't care not
only that what i'm telling you why i'm
particularly frustrated with this is
that even rekka giorgi the one person
who got bumped from the finals in her
complaint said i stand i fully stand
with leah thomas and you know she is no
different from me or any other d1
swimmer who wakes up every day and i
said then i am not going to do the work
for you and no one else should if they
have an issue with this they need to
only politely say they could they could
wear a pink ribbon they could wear a
little ribbon that says like i am
protesting this but i'll keep keep going
because i want my scholarships but
they're these are i am sick and tired of
people who are aware of what's going on
and apparently according to the mothers
they are but they won't speak publicly
who are refusing to stand up and and
stand up for their rights for whatever
reason they expect other people to do it
for them it's not going to happen
the left goes out and they throw bricks
through windows and they burn down
buildings and they've literally killed
dozens of people in the george floyd
riots kamala harris then helped bail
these people out 13 joe budden staffers
donated to help bail these people out
and republicans are like but i'm get
called a racist yeah i i'm sorry man if
you are unwilling to stand up for
yourself for your children if you were a
father unwilling to stand up for your
daughter and you think i'm gonna come
out and be like i will stand up for you
i'm not gonna do it
goes back to okay look at what we saw
for the past two years with the coveted
lockdowns right people's businesses
getting shut down all of us being forced
to mask up all of these things that we
had to do because the government told us
to i've been saying this since
15 days too slow the spread was
originally talked about this will not
end until the masses decide that it does
you are completely right in that tim
this does not end until the female
athletes decide that enough is enough
they're going to stand up they're going
to push back and they're going to put an
end to it i don't think they care i
think you guys are
are putting this view on them they
definitely care no no no no no no no no
no no no i i'll tell you this so this is
genuinely true and this is where i
actually want to agree with you about
the father thing yes but it's deeper
than that my point is is i'm not saying
because they care that i'm fighting and
i know this is not a popular statement
but number one i don't expect women to
be the fighters and the champions of
social movements and of the country i
think they can i think there's many
women who've done many great things but
i understand i don't believe it's in
their nature i believe in traditional
design and i think a lot of these women
women tend to be more submissive not all
women especially modern feminist women
but i think that's the natural design
and i don't think and i would blame
their fathers more or their boyfriends
or husbands more than them i would do
that but on the side
yeah
majority of millennial
was it 70 percent of wendell democrats
are female
feminism the i mean i think you have it
backwards women are the ones who are
consistently over the past 20 years
demanding social change yeah but this
yeah but it's in one direction so my
point is it's not in this direction and
so why aren't these feminine doing this
this is my point is i'm saying that
aside because you'd have to ascribe to a
traditional world view or believe in god
to really believe that probably or be
very well versed in science but i am
going to say is
why i care about it is not because i'm
not trying to get that 17th place person
i'm not petitioning so that she can get
back into 16th i don't care about this
because of them
i care about this because of what it
means for our country and for future
generations if we accept as a whole even
if that pool they all cared about you
know they don't care and whatever they
want to let it happen okay fine so if
there's a bunch of people in a house and
they just want to create a meth lab and
they're all cool with that should i be
cool with that no should i fight against
the idea of having major drug labs in
houses across the country yes even if
they are all for it and they're like
well you know the neighbors aren't mad
about it i'm like dude we're not gonna
have a country where you can just create
meth labs and blow up houses sorry not
going to be okay with that very very
very different no it but yes it's
different it's different when you see
something that's that's toxic that's bad
that's a social issue i'm using a
physical issue that people could
understand to a social issue when you're
allowing something to go out and not
just to happen because remember it's not
just the people in the in the pool the
swimmers are even the least important to
me on this you have espn et cetera
interviewing this this is being
reaffirmed nationally and as you know on
this show right now if i were to say
what i was really feeling about this
issue this live stream would get pulled
meaning it big tech is in on this as
well saying this is normal and normal
people are not and that's what i'm
saying
this is bs and i'm going to fight the
issue even if they won't because i don't
accept this for the comments i don't
agree with you on that i don't i don't
disagree with you on that my frustration
is with people who intended for
themselves i'm saying if we're going to
get pissed too
if we're talking specifically about the
greater issue by all means everybody who
wants to complain about it has a right
to complain about it yeah when we're
specifically talking about rekka gyorgy
as the one person to publicly complain
because she's the one person who got
bumped i'm like dude you had every
opportunity to speak up you didn't and
you're only complaining now because
you're the one person who got bumped
18th place isn't complaining because she
wouldn't have made it anyway and 16th
place isn't complaining because she did
make it i just don't see any principle
among those people and we already have
people mentioning this and i've answered
this several times who are saying if i
spoke up for my children i would lose my
job well then i understand what you find
to be more important security for your
family is more important than what your
children are going through with society
and with culture so what if i i'll i
said this before and i'll say it again
if if you're more concerned about you
know keeping your job and keeping your
income at least you'll know your kids
had a good meal
you know when when in 20 years they're
in the gulag sometimes speaking up is
actually dangerous the founding fathers
had to keep it under wraps if they'd
spoke up against george they would have
been executed on the block oh i
completely agree the the parents could
have come together on one night all all
sat down and said do we all agree we
have a problem here okay now that we've
all come together we can we can
unanimously issue a statement under our
names because we all know we have each
other yeah leah thomas technically isn't
doing anything wrong she's following the
rules so changing the rules is where the
key it lies how do you best change the
rules i can kind of jump in with you
guys on this because i do want to make
this point because i agree with a lot of
what you guys are saying but this is
when censorship comes into play so we
all know that many people on the right
wing many of these independent
journalists are being censored and why
is that it's because we are going out on
the ground and we are
elevating those unheard voices so right
now you guys are saying you're not
hearing from any of these athletes and
why is that it's because espn is
platforming
platforming leah thomas that's because
all of the mainstream is platforming
leah thomas as a hero they're not
platforming the uh adults and the
parents that are speaking out they're
not platforming platforming the app
they're not speaking out but they aren't
because i interviewed them last week and
guess what all of those interviews are
gone did you see any of my work from
last week why why did why did why did
the mother who came out and gave why did
she come out anonymously to the new york
post
again there but there's also parents
that came out they were not anonymous
they came out last week they had their
names they had their picture up on the
article but those stories are not
elevated and they're not promoted so i
understand what you're saying but
understand too that big tech is allowed
to uh you know regulate what the
narrative is so there are people that
are speaking out there are athletes that
are speaking out but their footage is
being deleted they are being censored
and they are being silenced because they
are not the popular uh you know
narrative that the big tech wants to
push oh yeah the swimmers could have you
know chosen to protest the swim mm-hmm i
agree i completely agree with you on
that but i'm saying that there are
voices
have publicly supported leah thomas and
we're talking in circles now so i think
it's i i get it you know if there are
people in this country have an issue
with what's happening in these schools
then i you know i actually i agree
if we're talking specifically about the
ncaa right now my problem is i am sick
and tired of the past 10 years where
there are people who know about the
problems who refuse to speak up i think
it was clifton clifton duncan said the
same thing he says is that something to
the effect of i am more what do you say
i'm more i have more disdain for those
who know what's happening and refuse to
speak than those who those who are
ignorantly participating in it something
that affect and that's where i've been
it for some time right the people who
say to me i know what they're doing to
my children in school that they're
grooming their kids and that they're
making up lies about you know the don't
say gay bill man if you come to me and
tell me you know what these teachers are
doing to your kids and that you'd rather
have your job than save your kids from
that i think you've got a very serious
problem with what's going to happen to
your children that that's mind blowing
but here but here's where where i have
to to think and not just react
i agree and and we're sitting in a room
of people who have chosen like you said
to not
allow what could happen bad to us or our
friends or family inhibit us from
pursuing what we believe god has called
us to or the universe or whatever you
ascribe to
my point is is that i am saddened that
in every culture there are warriors and
there are people who fight in an age of
information and intellectual property a
lot of the fighting happens in the
intellectual centers it's like back to
rome or to greece it's the battle of the
wits and of course there still is real
war and there people end up you know you
know deleting themselves with two shots
at the back of the head things still
happen there's still violence but
overall the fight is happening on the
public square and so a lot of different
souls that wouldn't basically not make
it on traditional battlefield are
somehow successful it basically values
uh intellect rather than just physical
might now i am saying that i understand
that wars have always been fought and
right now this war is being fought and i
don't mind you and i take hits all the
time everyone at this table does it is
so sad to me now that everybody is
forced to join the war now again to
concede to your point on this
there are times when the village gets
raided when the kingdom is under siege
and every able-bodied man i mean look at
ukraine they're not letting the young
men leave where it's like there is a
time to fight but i'm saying my point is
is that sometimes i think we're rushing
people because we're more alarmist and
see what's going on 14 years yes but but
to some yes but more people wake up you
would think after covid that everybody
would have woken up to what's going on
but they still didn't because the sleep
is so deep what's the second amendment
say
um it's the it's the right to a
well-armed militia basically the
security of a free state the right to
keep in bear arms et cetera uh a
well-regulated militia being necessary
for a free state and a militia was just
the people who were armed who would come
together when needed we didn't have
police forces back in the day we
actually had local militia that's how
things were dealt with so if somebody
stole they'd
round up all the people and be like you
know like arrest them and bring them to
the magistrate or whatever
and the founding fathers understood
everybody would have to fight to defend
their land what i see now is we are in a
a for we're now in year 14 of a major
culture war and it's going back to like
you know economic collapse the rise of
critical race theory occupy wall street
gamergate all of these things and you
have people who are like
i've been watching what's been happening
since donald trump social issues were a
major component of why many millennials
voted for donald trump and still they
say as war as bad as it has gotten and
as crazy as things have gotten i still
refuse to fight
but i'll be upset about it i guess now i
don't think anybody has to do anything i
mean look if you want something you have
to fight for it if you don't fight for
it i assume you don't want something i'm
not going to complain that these female
swimmers don't care enough to speak out
but that's reality are you saying no
nobody can avoid the war i'm asking if
that's what you're saying what i'm
saying is
to put it simply
if you place a person between two roads
and one is just keep swimming and keep
your head down and one is speak up and
stand up for your rights they're all
choosing the road they they think is
better for them that means they don't
care enough about leah thomas to
actually say anything i'm sure they're
upset about it because you can be you
know you can be mad about your choices
and choose the lesser of two evils or
something slightly worse
if you if if people really cared about
this if parents really cared about their
children they would look if you really
cared about your kids and you knew
teachers were grooming your kids you
would be homeless to save your child
from that right
let me ask you both which would you
prefer your child spends eight hours a
day being groomed by cult members
and you have you make 50 60 000 a year
or you're homeless and your kids are
safe with you so whether we'd have our
kids hang out with pete buddhist husband
or would be okay like i'm i'm like i'm
talking about what's going on in florida
yeah i mean
the kids matter but but i will say on to
the under that point real fast this is
where i think that that we're getting
confused on the argument and it's not
going in circles
just like i watched the the gay pride
parade in austin in that elementary
school i'm going i don't blame the kids
that are i think they're like eight nine
years old 10 years old i don't blame the
kids for you know anything about that i
would blame the teachers and my fight
would be with the teachers i i know this
is unpopular but i'm going to say this
but i was pointing to that i view people
who are asleep a lot of people who are
asleep
with the same way that i view children
is that they are not aware of what's
going on and i don't assume they all
know what's going on so i keep
accountable those that do and if there
are swimmers that are out there that
fully are aware of what's going on they
know what they're doing is wrong they
choose to do it then yes i would call
them out and i'm not asking you a
specific question because
you would rather be homeless safe with
your kids yeah cause i'd figure out
another way to make money well so the
response we get every time i bring this
up and we have super chats right here
saying this exact thing is i can't speak
up because i would lose my job you know
and my kids need to eat and things like
that
in west virginia
school you think it's the second most
trump supporting state in the country
you'd think the schools are going to be
republican they're not yeah the school
board members who are voted in are woke
there are kids in west virginia schools
who are being groomed and indoctrinated
and there are parents who say i don't
care enough
to risk my security and that includes my
children's security now i can fully
understand you prioritize your kid
having a full belly over
being away from groomers i personally
disagree
i don't have kids so maybe i can't speak
to it and that's fine but i typically
ask most people and they give me the
same response i would rather be homeless
and unsure of how i'm going to eat and
my kids than leave my children in the
hands of a groomer for eight hours every
day at these schools my question is then
why so many parents do it and i think
it's because the parents many of them
don't know and i'll and i'll totally uh
contend to that and we're fighting every
day to inform them
but many of the parents do know and tell
me well i don't want to lose my job okay
i'm look no disrespect you've chosen it
we had uh um we had andrew heaton on
and i was explaining he's you know mill
the road guy and he says both sides you
know i take issue with still libertarian
and uh uh i think is it legitimate
yeah i said
the the right makes their arguments
based off of
the they they present facts they can
prove to you and then from those facts
will give you their opinion on why their
policy ideas are correct the left will
lie to you about what the problem is
because the ends justify the means to
convince you to side with them
and his response was that i was
describing the left as you know bad or
evil and the right as moral and i said
no no i'm not
the left literally will tell you this by
any means necessary in their books they
write the strategy of of keeping secrets
they there's undercover video being
exposed right now something from
accuracy and media was going viral where
teachers are saying we're going to
change the language but keep crt in
schools we can't let the parents know
this is exactly what they'll tell you
they're doing what i said to them was if
you think that i'm describing them as
good or evil it's because you view one
side as good or evil not because i've
ascribed that to them the right does
this they'll say look at this fact it's
not from me it's proof right therefore
here's my my argument on on moral issues
or whatever the left will say here's a
manipulation to trick you into agreeing
with me we see it all the time in the
press these are tendencies not absolutes
when it comes to somebody who says
you know i can't speak up because my
kids or whatever
what they're really saying is deep down
they know their kid being this position
is very wrong and bad but they prefer to
keep their kid with the groomer than
lose their job
actions speak louder than words and if i
could answer now too i would have the
same exact answer as elijah to say you
know i would rather be homeless and take
care of my child and protect my kids but
what you just laid out there tim is
exactly where our country is where it is
today because if push comes to shove and
i think about this all the time with the
second amendment right if push comes to
shove how many americans do you think if
the police were at their door right now
and said give us your guns or we will
kill you how many of them would just
give up their guns willingly and give up
their second amendment and rights people
do not understand that standing up for
your rights means you are willing to die
for your rights and you need to be ready
to die for your rights for your freedoms
every single day people don't seem to
understand that because we've been so
cuddled as a society because we face no
real challenges as you know in this
country and so people so willingly give
away their rights and freedoms which is
why for the past year we've watched
people say i don't want to get
vaccinated but i'm going to do it to
keep my job because the government told
me to do it if the government tells me
to take four or five six boosters i will
do it because they told me to people do
not have
the uh mentality that they need to fight
for the rights and die for them and they
don't get it which is why we're here
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you